o botafogo está nós vimos aqui contra
suas páginas na história que começou há
cerca de 10 mil homens pra nós estamos a
nove anos atrás de espanha e américa e
foi nos conhecemos eu aguentar um campo
amor a amizade com graves e um filho
cada pena também às vezes mencionado
como da minha escolha nós gostamos de
enfrentar mente
o ambiente também vai fazer um que é
impossível acabar o curso de engenharia
e - certamente não vão conseguir
nós como é óbvio não opinou que a itália
se fosse pra frente e alguém fim qual
estava previsto acabar com nosso curso
de nível médio
mas o fim do curso olhamos um para o
outro e pensar que nós estamos vivendo
nós somos mesmo bons e gostamos e mesmo
de jogar videojogos
era fantástico nós conseguimos trabalhar
nessa área não era possível o segundo
mito que querem vender jogos em portugal
totalmente impossível não é solução
fomos procurar um grupo de investigação
na área da computação gráfica com os
trâmites não só trabalhar na área de
jogos como também precisamos aprender
mais sobre o ju e foi aí que nós
conhecemos este grupo de investigação
incrível 11 ensinaram não só criar
personagens para o jogo em três filmes
como também as áreas de vida o pisando
mas nem mensal e também temos a
oportunidade de participar em projectos
ainda mais fantástico está com um jogo
para crianças autistas um projeto da
virtual europeu ou trabalharmos com os
meus investigadores do mundo nesta área
no entanto os projetos também terminam
agora o que nós vamos fazer
e foi
saiu o terceiro mito por que não criar
uma conta uma empresa que combina três
dentes de jogos em portugal serão os que
vão espalhar drasticamente esta
indústria nunca funciona em portugal e
que não temos mercado para isso não
ficar nos braços cruzados
obviamente nós vamos recordar os
problemas da indústria e vamos ver como
é que nossa investigação conseguir ser
aplicada de forma a dar mais valor à
agroindústria
o quarto míssil josé muito já é um mito
da indústria dos videojogos do filme
disseram nos que não era possível que o
vencedor comum como vocês para criar seu
personagem em 3d
entendo que as crianças são personagens
3d e envolve o trabalho manual
normalmente de vários profissionais com
elevado grau de desperdício tornando
assim o processo não foi muito lento mas
também muito caro
claro já existem as funções no carro que
ao menos um dos processos para 31 e 1º
super complexo por cacho ou juntar sul
menos bons
e foi aí que nós olhamos pra nós
estávamos a fazer a nossa inscrição e
eficaz nós com câmeras fotográficas
comum
conseguimos capturar a cara da pessoa e
criar automaticamente personagens 3d são
por si sós com ela vê pedro e melhor
utilizado acaba de conseguir capturar os
movimentos faciais do cruzador e em
tempo real criar a alimentação
então quem é ser mãe
e foi assim que nós criar a nossa
ferramenta que usam perfis capturadas
por um telemóvel automaticamente
qualquer pessoa é baixo custo e forma
muito rápida não pode criar seu
personagem em 3d é mesmo complexo podem
ver
ou seja por dia em cada um de vocês que
vocês fizeram nossa reflexão e podem
criar o nosso nosso relacionando os
duplos virtuais como podem ver o peru
neste preciso momento só fizeram
equipamentos realidade virtual
não sei se algum de vocês realmente não
conhece mas não possa vencer porque
estes equipamentos vão chegar ao mercado
mesmo em portugal já em 2007 elas
permitem que a pessoa seja incluída
dentro não tinha câmera virtual
outro agente todo o sangue imaginem anos
vivia jogo tudo que vocês quiserem peso
quando ela como é que a experiência
passou por baixo do estádio estar neste
momento dentro de um vídeo jogo está uma
notável já saber é o próprio utilizando
o seu duplo virtual
talvez mais tarde possam dizer que cão
vocês verde goulart que é exatamente
igual a mim e quais são as
potencialidades tudo isto já se
imaginaram no filme é contra as
narcossalas atriz pública
o melhor é trocar em palco conversa a
banda favorita
ao chegarem no futuro guarda costeira
canal não é
ou seja nós pequenos em cada um de vocês
não temos equipamentos coisa virtual e
com a nossa aplicação criamos um
personagem virtual com os leva a todo
lado e foi isso um dos resultados de
termos ultrapassado este movimento né e
mitos da parecem cm e vamos pra fazer
circular através das nossas vidas
pessoas ou situações que vão dizer que
tenha firam determinado conjunto de
regras para alcançar um determinado
objetivo
quando isso acontecer você não lembra
nem passou com nove gols não é porque
vocês porque vocês mesmos vocês podem
ver que vocês quiserem dentro ou fora do
número pai abrigado